I prayed for that President almost every  day during our Administration  and he was dismissive about it at first  don't don't bother but then as I a few  minutes later as I got up to leave the  room I looked at him as he sat at the  end of the little table in the dining  room just off the Oval Office  and I said well I guess there's just two  things we're probably always going to  disagree on  and he looked up at me and  faintly said what  and I said refer to my role on January  6.  and then I said  I'm never going to stop praying for you  and he looked at me and  said that's right don't don't ever  change yeah now we parted amicably does  anybody believe that story and and the  the biggest lie seems to be the last  thing we parted amicably Trump doesn't  part amicably with people he just  doesn't but I don't believe a word of  that story